cho tôi về ta ở đây là mình khó phải là hành người đến gắn đi dừa và
và nước đẩy nằm in xa, nhưng nước đẩy mình không nhận đà mình xa
và chỉ có sự chưởng thành dân dận với nhìn đà đẹp nào
là chúng ta đang xa, để đẩy được tình yêu của tôi chuyện ở những bạn thân một tóan
để món bản ấy, kinh nằm đúng một bản thân rất tích quả trời đúng
Nếu kinh ngu làm lại, cho tôi khi đã phản trận một trong người trong khu
hay là game set mỏ qua
và game show rằng thôi, bạn hoặc có giải cũng trả hiểu
vài mấu chút, nằm ở chỗ nó chủ rất là thân phát biết mình xa ở đâu
và lỗi hồng gần thích nào, với nên chúng ta và sau đó cái vị hợp bản chất để hả gái cho đúng hơn
như vậy thì những nằm sau, đập lại là mại đầy, đà mình không sai được